θέμείς πραπά τησεις κυμι δεν πάτησς κουμιά το σύστημα με τα πρόπτα γαι γνότα με
τα πρόπτα νοτα των αποδράζεων το δόλοφωνιο να πρόπτασουν τα ιοντα τα οποία πολλές φορές
ο κόσμός νομίζει ότι αστυνομία μπορά τα προλάβει όιλα όμως εσύ οφίλησαν αστυνομία α λιτουργά
σωστά σε ελάθει και παραλψεισι ότοσότε και το απρόπτο και γονός μιας αποδράσεις να πορεις
να το καλύψεις οσόν αφορά τη δράσι σου άρα δεν είναι τόσο θέμα προσώπο τα
πρόσωπαθέλουκ αναπατήσουν κουμια να κάμουν μετάριθμίσεις για να μποράσουν να προλάβουν τα πρόπ τα ιγονότα
τα πρώπτα ιγονότα ανκίνα που αιο ξανούλιος τους αρχηγούς αστυνομία καιο υπουργούς διγοσύνης άαπλά τα
πράγματα όπως είναι για παράδειγμα ναι αποδράσεις π το τελευταίο διάστημα δεν ξέρω για πιο
λόγο υπάρχει αυτόν το πρόβλημα καταρχάς να χωρίσουμε τα αποδράσεις ότι αποδράσει του κόμμο ότι
δεν είχε καμ να σχέση μετνπμε τις αποδράσεις τς πολύπεται να τς αστυνομίας που τανγια
υπολύ πε αντιρααταρασις δεν έχουμε βρασιολάκια έχουμε συνεχώς μεταφορές για δεν έχουμε κιγιά εν έχουμε
δομάτια αστα νοσογομία και και ιιολογιγές τις ναμοςπω προσωπικές ευθύνες είτει θέμαναανίοντα επιδαρχηκές για να
με πάραεξηγούμαστε έγο λέω κάποια πράγματα κάποιες παραμέτρους οι οποίας μιώνουν το πωσ ωστό απόδρασις
ωραία όταν των τα πράγματα έντα έσεις μένεις μόνος στων ανθρώπινον παράγοντα το ανθρώπινος παράγοντας
αντιλαμβάνεσαι υποπτέπτη πεύτεις ελάθισε ο παραλίψεις αν τοπάρουμενετις αραβράκιολά κια δομάτιος τα νοσοκομία λιγότερες μεταφορές
καταδικών και καλύτερες σευθήκες στα δικαστήρια διτι οπαδικαστήρια έθαμεν από αποπύρες αποδράσεις γιατί το οργανωμένων
έγκλημαείναι έναν ιδύο βήματα πιο μπροστά από την ασθυνό το οργανουμενο έκλημα εξεγχρονίστηκε επίες σε
άλλες μορφές εμείς ε παραμείναμε στο ίδιο ριχό μόνο πάτει τ υτό χρονα έναν πάρα
οπόλού να σημαντικών βήμα που πρέπει να γάνομα με όισ αναστυνομία δεν έδική μας ευθυνί